ce soldat ukrainien tente de se couvrir
dans une tranchée
autour de lui des bombes des tonnes sur
la route qui mène à dos niet il y à un
peu plus d'un mois les russes ont
intensifié leur offensive dans le
donbass à l'est de l'ukraine objectif
conquérir les derniers territoires des
régions de louhansk et donetsk encore
sous contrôle craignant l'armée russe la
firme le conflit va bel et bien dur et
n'allons opérations militaires spéciales
jusqu'à la réalisation de tous les
objectifs en porte les occidentales au
régime de kiev les russes occupent déjà
la grande majorité du donbass et
concentre désormais tous leurs efforts
pour s'emparer de la dernière poche ici
en jaune sévère au dos n'y est ce qu est
quasiment encerclée
bombardé jour et nuit le sort de cette
ville rappelle t-il celui de marioupol
la cité portuaire pratiquement rasée par
les russes tout obstacle qui se trouve
devant cette armée russe automatiquement
balayé bombardé écrasé rayés de la carte
donc on va que globalement les marioupol
et les ai laissés l'euro donnait ce
qu'on se multiplier temps qu'on y seront
sur le l'itinéraire ou sur l' axe de
cette espèce de de force brute qui veut
a qu'un seul objectif qui selon les
autorités ukrainiennes 12500 soldats
russes seraient ainsi engagé dans cette
attaque au coeur du débat